[Musique]
le musée royal de l'ontario est connu
pour ses dinosaures
c'est dans sa nouvelle galerie
permanente n'est pas si impressionnante
créatures que le musée met de l'avant
mais plutôt les organismes qui les ont
précédés l'histoire de la vie avant les
dinosaures ce sont des périodes qui sont
pas bien exposé dans cette galerie
intitulée l'aube de la vie les visiteurs
font un retour de 4 milliards d'années
dans le passé grâce à l'exposition deux
milliers de fossiles ce sont des faux
cils qui nous ont une histoire
exceptionnelle sur l'origine des animaux
et aussi te noies aux régions
la plupart de ces fossiles viennent du
canada et de zones montagneuses comme
les chaises de bridge s en
colombie-britannique meilleur royal
thériault a commencé afin des les
recherches sur ce site en 1975 et
aujourd'hui on a la plus grande
collection au monde
l'île d'anticosti est aussi mis en
valeur avec ses faux cils unique datant
d'une période glaciaire anticosti
représente la première extension de
masse de l'histoire de la vie tout au
long de leur promenade les visiteurs
découvrent d'autres épisodes climatiques
extrêmes qui ont mené à la destruction
d'écosystèmes entier pour jean bernard
caron des parallèle s'impose c'est une
réflexion sur la protection de notre
environnement aujourd'hui si l'espèce
c'est à ces des millions d'années
d'évolution qui s'éteint c'est pas juste
cette espèce en misant sur de nombreux
outils interactifs le musée royal de
l'ontario espérer attirer un public plus
jeune
un pari visiblement remporter quoi que
les parents y trouvent aussi leur compte
c'est bien parce que ça nous force à
utiliser notre imagination dans cette
maman
un enthousiasme qui réjouit jean bernard
caron le paléontologue s'étant découvert
une passion pour les fossiles à l'âge de
9 ans je pense qu'il ya des enfants qui
vont vouloir dernière par les notes qui
sont maintenant dans le futur
il aura fallu une décennie au musée pour
inaugurer cette galerie qui restera
ouverte pour au moins 30 ans
mehdi radio canada toronto